all right so today we're gonna be
talking about something that's not quite
directly perf related if you talked or
if you were at Colts keynote earlier
this morning and you could understand
what he was saying he said yes perf
matters and perf does matter but it it
doesn't matter quite so much if you
can't get the user you need signed in or
signed up to the app that you're
building so that's what we're gonna talk
to talk about today is how you can get
users signed up or signed into your apps
a lot more easily by using a variety of
different technologies on Android and
ones that are provided by Google so just
to give you a little bit of an
introduction my name is Steven I work on
the identity team at Google and identity
at Google is really about knowing who
the user is so knowing that that it's
them when they come to see their Gmail
and that it's not the bad guys keep the
bad guys out and over the years we've
we've been thinking a lot about how to
get the Google users signed in but in
doing that and keeping all of those
Google users secure we've come up with a
pretty strong account system that could
be very useful to the third party
ecosystem to all of the app developers
that are out there who are thinking
about how to get their users signed in
or signed up and it's probably a problem
that you might have encountered yourself
if you're building an app I certainly
before coming to Google actually worked
at a bunch of startups and this is I
think one of the fundamental problems
that if you need to have some kind of
account system for your users to be able
to keep track of their information to be
able to personalize content to them you
need to know who they are and it can be
a real barrier to actually have somebody
sign up or sign into a service it's
something that where you could have in
fact a lot of the apps that we work with
have seen that in the order of 50
percent of the people who see their
login screen just take off or fail to
login in the first place and so that is
there's really a major problem if you
know 50 percent of the potential people
who are using your app for your service
are going to evaporate right away before
they even get in the door so thinking
about that and putting it kind of in the
perspective of all these things you have
to think about performance and getting
users into your apps making sure that
that is as frictionless as possible is
really one of the key ones that you have
to keep in mind and so that's what we're
going to talk about here some of the
solutions the
you've probably heard about before
things like Google sign-in if you've
wandered around the web you see these
Google sign-in buttons all over the
place and it is a really nice solution
it certainly gives you the ability to
login with with a click without having
to create more usernames and passwords
it's kind of the opportunity to replace
some of these password logins that
you've maybe used in the past but it's
not the complete solution in that there
are still apps and sites out there that
use passwords and usernames and we have
to think about what to do there and
that's what one of the new technologies
that I'd like to talk about today which
is this concept of smart lock for
passwords or an API to save login
information that users have collected in
the past through Chrome through the
password manager there and be able to
make it available programmatically on
Android so very cool and I think it's
one of the most exciting things that
we've seen in 1/10 ocation space in a
long time so just to get into what I'll
cover today and give you the quick
overview there's Google sign-in and I'll
give you a little bit of an update of
what we're doing there but basically
Google sign-in is this cross-platform
solution it works on iOS and Android and
on the web that it makes signing in or
signing up really easy that it enables
access to a lot of other Google API so
very useful there and that it can
facilitate some nice things like being
able to download an Associated app from
your website so that's been around for a
while and I kind of use this analogy of
comparing the Google sign-in which is
like a replacement for the different
keys you may use to login to different
services around the web you can kind of
imagine going from site to site and each
one presents like a door that you have
to unlock you have to have a different
key and over over time you accumulate a
lot of these keys they get pretty heavy
in your pocket and you kind of end up in
this situation where it's nice to have a
Google sign in but you still have a lot
in your pocket to worry about and to
kind of complete the analogy then the
idea behind a smart lock for passwords
is that you can put all these keys on a
keychain kind of in the same idea as a
password manager but by making it a
programmatic interface we can do a lot
more that we can build user interfaces
that don't even involve a sign-in screen
anymore if you can programmatically pull
login information up
for a given user so that's that's one of
the really exciting pieces and I'll show
you some some pieces of the UI and what
it looks like and how you can integrate
it in your your app too but in short
it's a cross-platform single sign-in
solution
working on Android right now and there's
API is in the beta Channel for Chrome as
well
save and retrieve that login information
could be username passwords but also
more generally as a as an API in fact
saving other kinds of login whether a
user signed in with Google or with
Facebook or Twitter and making that all
available the next time they come back
so that they don't have to think about
kind of the new problem that has been
introduced by all these other different
ways to log in which is to remember
which button was clicked let alone what
a username or the password was and how
to link all of those together those are
really being addressed by this more
broad solution in smart lock for
passwords we've had a quite a bit of
luck actually with getting partners on
board with this smart lock for passwords
set of api's you can see some icons of a
few noteworthy ones we launched with
earlier this year netflix new york times
linkedin coming soon Orbitz Eventbrite
which you might have even used a few if
you had your tickets through Eventbrite
today and Instagram but before I get
into the smart lock for passwords I just
wanted to talk a little bit about what
the latest on sign-in is so Google
sign-in or in the past what you probably
had seen or it maybe have been planted
in your own app is Google+ sign-in so
this has really been changing over the
last few months that you no longer need
a Google+ account for many things at
Google and that includes signing in so
if you have used the API in the last few
months since we've updated it on Android
on iOS and on the web you'll see that
the default set of things that your
Google sign-in implementation asks for
no longer includes Google+ information
it's what we call the basic set of
profile scopes so that's things like
email information about the user's name
and profile picture and with that more
basic set of information you can brand
it and by default it's now branded just
with the plain Google logo the new a new
one with the colors that we put out
there just last month
and really much a much cleaner
experience for the end-user I'll show
you exactly what it looks like in a sec
but the general idea here again is that
this is the gateway to all of googles
API is that it's not just knowing who
the user is on google the name and the
email address but in fact having access
to things like their contacts be able to
pull messages out of their Gmail store
things and drive upload to YouTube
anything you can imagine payment
information and a lot of other really
useful stuff so not just the
authentication piece but also the
authorization piece but in talking about
that we should really see what the UI
looks like now in this streamlined model
where if you've used a Google+ sign-in
in the past you might have seen some of
these the older API on Android looked
like that first screen which kind of
harks back to the old days of Android
with the holo theme that's kind of on
the way out with the material worlds
these days the new API on Android I
should actually mention that this new
API is rolling out right now so if
you're looking to build it into your app
what wait for the next the next play
services update it will be it will be in
there and with it you get this very nice
UI so just to say that this is like a
one tap experience now that if you click
on the plain Google sign-in button
you'll get a picker for which account
you want to sign in with that's the
basic profile set of information very
clean one tab and it replaces a lot of
what users had some frustration or road
bumps in the process before which is
things like kind of the ugly picker the
having to create a Google+ account if
they didn't have one already and then
kind of boasts wall of text around
getting access to circles information
things like that that for a lot of apps
in reality didn't didn't end up using so
kind of a barrier to getting into your
app quickly and easily and so that's
it's one of the big pieces that have
been addressed here and certainly if you
are an Android developer who's put this
into your app do take a look at the
latest API is as they come out because
you'll have this much streamlined
experience and then you can also then
what we say incrementally ask for
additional scopes additional
permissions to access the users Google
data things like contacts and so on and
be able to do it then in context so one
tap sign in and then at the time you
need to access contact information to
send messages for example you can do it
then and have the user understand what
that is actually being used for so
really aligning nicely with the device
level permissions that you might be
seeing in Android with the with the
marshmallow release okay so that's kind
of the latest on sign-in so watch out
for that one coming in the next couple
weeks on Android but to get into the
smart lock for passwords side of things
so I mentioned this earlier but
basically using something like a Google
sign-in is this opportunity to replace
the password so have kind of a super key
that you can use across the doors that
you encounter on the web and no longer
have to remember these passwords or come
up with new ones for the sites that you
encounter but again like I said not
everyone uses Google sign-in or Facebook
or Twitter sign-in there's still a lot
of people out there who for whatever
reason choose or prefer to login with
passwords and there are a lot of sites
that still use passwords for whatever
legacy reason they've been around for a
long time they have established user
bases they just prefer having their own
proprietary login system with their own
username and passwords and that does
present a problem like if you've got
that heavy pocketful of keys then you
might think about ways to lighten the
load that if you just went out there and
used one key across all the doors that
you came across then you'd only have
that one torii about or if you used a
really simple light one that's easy to
remember an easy password you can
certainly light in your pocket but it
can also introduce a pretty major
security vulnerability which is that if
that one key that you rely on get stolen
gets picked out of your pocket then
people can basically walk through all of
the doors that you would encounter and
if that key is really light and simple
easy to counterfeit you have the same
problem so thinking about how to
encourage people to move to stronger
passwords make them easier to use and
then eventually move to ways to move
beyond passwords is really where we're
trying to get the industry to to go and
by providing these api's to the
third-party ecosystem on and
we hope to make that a lot easier so let
me get into smart lock for passwords and
again I'll just motivate it by saying
that this is probably one of the things
that as an app developer you're really
conscious of that there's a lot of time
and effort and energy that goes into
marketing the apps or the services that
you're building to make people aware of
what it is that you're offering to them
and to get them to download the app can
be a pretty expensive and time-consuming
process and that's just the beginning
then you have to get them to open it to
get engaged and that means potentially
signing up for an account or signing in
and that can be a very very friction 'fl
process that as soon as people see that
screen where they have to create yet
another account like I said earlier in
the apps that we've worked with there's
often 50% or more bounce rate there that
those users are evaporating right off
the bat so much for all of the marketing
and the download effort that went into
that user and that even if they do sign
in it's very often the case that it
wasn't the first attempt that succeeded
there was a wrong password in there that
you picked on a different provider and
it's asking you to link accounts or do
something really confusing all
problematic and I think like the
opportunity here is that to get to that
bottom of the funnel to get the really
engaged user you can use something like
smart lock to make it completely
seamless so to to get rid of this
conversion killer and just to make it
clear how this works as an API I'll walk
through a bit of an example with with
some UI but just to kind of give you the
architecture here like I mentioned
earlier one way to think about it is
that there are users who have probably
been using Chrome for years and stored a
lot of their login information I've have
a lot of my information in the cloud in
this way basically stored with their
Google accounts all the passwords
they've gone and entered to different
sites that they've they've come across
on the web and a lot of that information
is very valuable that it would be great
if you could access that on Android and
a native app your Associated app with
your website and that's what mate is
made possible here by these api's that
we're calling part of the smart lock
suite of technologies to basically make
sign-in and authentication
wherever you go really easy so it's all
backed by this code of
the Google account stored information
login information like passwords and
let's see how it works in an app like a
publisher app for example New York Times
so New York Times launched with us and
you can imagine a scenario like this
you're a New York Times reader you've
set up on your phone for example
subscription to The New York Times enter
your payment information all of a really
invested user and you've put a lot of
effort into setting up this account on
your phone now the problem is that you
know maybe you have a second device or
you buy a tablet something like that and
now you open up the New York Times app
and it shows you the login screen yet
again and it could very well have been
the case that you set up that New York
Times account a long time ago that it
could have been a year ago and now you
have no idea what email address you used
what the password was and then it's a
very very painful experience of
recovering that for the New York Times
they have to provide support to all
these users who are their paid customers
to be able to get back into their
accounts so that's really an opportunity
and so if you think about this sort of
new device or second device you can
imagine that we've done a lot of work to
get that device bootstrapped
to get all of the apps and services that
you previously using an Android
available right there we call this the
tap and go set up experience where all
of the apps are kind of put back onto
the new device there even in the same
place but again this fundamental problem
of opening that app and seeing but it's
not signed in so now look what the
experience is with this API integration
as soon as that New York Times app is
opened there's a notification here to
the user this is a first-run experience
the text is a little bit hard to read on
the screen here but basically what it's
saying is that you've been signed back
in automatically with information that
you saved with Google so the last time
you use this on an Android device you
opted in to save whatever login from
information that you input and now it's
been retrieved programmatically by the
app the app is able to look at what kind
of login information is available for
this user and then it be able to
basically use it to skip the login
screen so just think about that for a
second that it's not just the experience
that you've seen in Chrome where your
username and password is filled in and
the user still has to find the login
page it's that this user just opens up
the app and they're in just like that
and then of course being the cross
solution you can think about other
scenarios where this is really powerful
so let's use Eventbrite for a second
example and like I said earlier
Eventbrite was one of the ticketing apps
I think for this event and probably for
a lot of others that you might encounter
and maybe this time you start on the web
where you actually made the purchase of
tickets or something like that and you
could very well have being an event
bright user for a long time in chrome
and over the years come to save
passwords for events or for for sites
like Eventbrite in the chrome password
manager and if you've signed in to
Chrome then you've basically synced all
of this information up to the cloud
you've saved it with your Google account
and if you go to another device with
Chrome it'll very helpfully fill it in
for you but of course you end up in an
app and so maybe you're in the line here
and you need to show your ticket
everybody's waiting behind you and if
you open up the app and realize that you
need to log in to get that ticket it can
be pretty stressful to you know type
that in with your thumbs as well
everyone's waiting and hope that you've
got the right password so the experience
now if you just open up the app with
this integration in it and you can try
this out yourself if you you might
already be signed into Eventbrite but if
you uninstall and and reinstall it you
can actually see how it will just sign
you and automatically don't give you
this blue bar at the bottom that says
your login information and from that
point on again you've basically just
skipped the entire login flow and you as
an app developer you can think about how
valuable this is that you can skip all
of the warm welcomes and the things that
are just getting in the way of your
really engaged and most valuable users
getting to their content okay so that's
Eventbrite and and let's walk through
maybe one more example so think about
moving in the other direction and
thinking about some of the other
powerful things that this API can do so
suppose you're you know we're setting up
your flights or your travel information
to the big Android BBQ and in order to
do that you had to of course go to a
travel website and probably look up some
flight information and plan an itinerary
that kind of thing
one of the big ones out there that I
like using is Orbitz and we've got them
onboard with this API as well and the
idea here then is that you could start
all of your travel planning do all of
your research on mobile on a phone or
tablet and then you can save it and use
it in Chrome or on other platforms but
there's more to it than that with this
API is actually pretty powerful in that
there's more than just the save and
retrieve API there's another one that we
provide also coming out in the update in
a in a week or two the version that's
rolling out right now it's basically
this ability to help the user sign up in
the first place and so how this works is
basically if the person has saved their
login information for a variety of
different apps and sites and they've got
a Google account then we know some
information about them we know which
email addresses they use the different
ways that they log in and we can present
to the end-user basically this dialog at
the time that they need to sign in you
can have them pick if your system is
based on email addresses or we're on
phone numbers basically have them pick
the information that they need to sign
in with so the email address that they
prefer and the nice thing about this if
you've been working with em or
permissions on marshmallow is that this
dialog calling into the Play services
doesn't actually require any device
permissions so now you've got something
very very useful here that you don't
need to ask for get accounts or don't
ask me I need to ask for phone number
permission anymore you can have the user
give you that information
by calling into a Play services API so
they pick that email address and then in
fact if you think about some of the
optimizations to your app that you could
do you could actually put the user into
the right flow if they're an existing
user know that they need to sign back in
know how they should be logging in for
that email address for example or you
can intelligently put them into a signup
flow so in the case of this example
let's say that we'll just do an account
creation here or sign in to an existing
account so you have to put in the
username and the password so let's just
suppose it's a password account but that
said you could do very well the same
thing for the different types other
different types of login that if the
user were to sign in with Google or with
Facebook you have that opportunity once
they've entered this information to save
that pointer basically that it was a
Facebook or a Google sign-in and that's
what you should trigger the next time so
we'll take a look at the how that looks
in a sec but basically at the
point that they've entered this
information they get a prompt that says
would you like to save the password that
you've entered this is the opt-in to
basically store the information with
Google it's very similar in
functionality to what you've probably
seen in Chrome where there's a bubble
that pops up and there's a save and no
thanks
same idea here that they opted in to
save that information to the Google
account and then once it's stored in the
cloud then it's available it's synced
across all the different platforms it's
synced to Chrome and then in fact if you
go to Chrome you can see that
information filled in so you can try
this out yourself in the Orbitz app it's
live along with the other partners
basically the ability to go from one
platform to the other have that
information and fill in using the
existing chrome password manager but in
fact there's even better stuff coming
than in the chrome beta channel right
now we've been working with the
community to basically put a spec out
there a web spec that enables password
management or credential management more
generally as a programmatic API in the
browser so if you read up on the spec
navigator about credentials you can
check for that available availability of
that API in the browser you're using
coming to Chrome pretty soon and
basically if that API is available then
you can do the same programmatic
functionality that I've described on
Android in the browser so imagine going
from your Android app to the Chrome on
the same device and having those two in
sync because you know these know the
user in both places or going to an
another device altogether where this
person potentially has never visited
your site before but since the Google
account is there you can do an automatic
sign-in so they could show up through
search results something like that and
have a completely seamless experience
and that really highlights one of the
values here that I think makes this
interesting to Google into the ecosystem
as a whole is that this just enables the
the end user who doesn't even really
understand the concept of saving
credential information or how it works
and just give them the seamless
experience as they go across the web
whether they're coming through search
results or they're going to your website
directly their state is there and
they're put into the place that they
need to be pick up right where they are
left off and the ability to re-engage
and give them the best experience
possible so that's kind of an overview
of how basically the UI works and how
how it looks in apps that you might see
see out there right now in fact I just
looked up this morning who's using the
API right now and I already showed you
some examples of big ones like Netflix
with their TV app coming out as well the
idea that you can sign in on Android or
Chrome and then be signed in on an
Android TV as well so that's pretty cool
and times an Eventbrite Orbitz instacart
others but some nice big ones that have
launched recently are a TripAdvisor
overstock fancy gold star another
ticketing app and some big ones coming
soon like LinkedIn tune in Evernote
Groupon Ticketmaster and lots more
internationally - ones like eBay's
properties around the world all of these
apps and sites basically leveraging this
opportunity to keep their users signed
in so let me talk a little bit about
what you actually need to do to put this
into the app or the site that you're
building so I'll focus on the Android
side today since we're at an Android
developer conference and if you'd like
to find out more about this we're going
to run a code lab tomorrow
so in fact what I'll show you in a sec
here is that it's pretty simple it's
just a couple of API calls and you could
probably come to the session tomorrow
and get it implemented in your app so if
there's anything that you take away from
the conference this might be a good one
you can get this very high ROI like very
very big improvement to the login flow
of your app by just adding a few lines
of code so the first thing you need is
that Play services on the latest version
so many of you probably already have
Play services in your app probably
wouldn't be too big an issue to move
over to the latest version and then from
there basically how it works is when the
app starts you call into the API and you
say hey are there any credentials saved
for the current users on this device and
so of course this is backed by the
Google account and on Android the vast
majority of people are signed in with a
Google account they have the ability to
store this information and in fact if
they've already saved something in
Chrome it could very well be the case
that even if you're launching this
integration your Android app I knew that
they already have something saved from
Chrome we've seen in the order of 10 to
15% just right off the bat to get an
automatic sign-in experience so that's
pretty cool so what you do is you call
request you wait for a callback and then
you look at the result and the result
could be a couple of different
here that I'll walk through there's
either exactly one credential available
and this is the Auto sign end scenario I
the idea being that you get a successful
result back you look inside and see what
kind of credential it was I mentioned
earlier that it could very well be the
case that it's not just a username
password credential it could be the fact
that they signed in with Google or
Facebook the token for those kind of
sign ins isn't actually stored in the
API it's just a pointer it says ah this
user signed in with Facebook last time
you should trigger the Facebook flow and
make sure that have Facebook validate or
Google validate or Twitter validate that
this is the same user as before so
that's the the kind of scenario for a
so-called federated or identity provider
login but then of course there's still
the scenario where this person logged in
with the password and then you simply
get the password back and you can
imagine the experience for an automatic
sign-in is basically filling out the
fields for them and tapping the button
but the nice thing there is that you
don't even need to show them that UI you
can hide this behind the splash screen
of your app and all they see is the nice
blue bar on top of the splash screen and
the the next view that they've got after
that is the signed-in state picking up
wherever they left off from the last
session or the last device so you have
to do you think do you think about a
couple of corner cases so one of the
common ones is if someone has multiple
credentials saved for example this could
be a shared device where you have
multiple people signed in they've saved
information into different accounts and
the idea here is that we need to have
some disambiguation that one of the the
person who's seeing this screen the
login experience is that they'll
actually have to pick between the two or
more credentials it's also the scenario
that if they for their account have
disabled automatic sign-in one of the
Google settings they're not the default
but there are a few people who you know
want to have that level of control which
is nice be able to pick the credential
that they want to to sign in with and to
kind of detect that in in the code that
you write you basically just check for
this state resolution required in the
result that you get back if it's
resolution required then you can fire
off an intent at whatever point in your
UI fits in and then the idea is that
you'll be called back when the user
one of the safe credentials or they
could very well cancel and you know
create a new account something like that
so then under the scenario that there's
nothing saved in the API you have to
think kind of going back to that Orbitz
example that we talked about that what
do you do if there's nothing saved and a
nice thing here is just is that this is
just a API on top of whatever you've
already built so basically you could
very well just operate in the scenario
that this API were not there that the
user is going to have to manually select
or input their login information and
this is works out perfectly well that
it's it's certainly not a loss of what
anything that you currently had but now
you've got a couple of opportunities
here one is that you can check in this
state that if it's valuable you can use
that picker I showed earlier that you
can have them tap with with with one
action the identifier that they need the
email address or the phone number and
use that to bootstrap the sign-in
process or you could just use the
existing flow and if you go through the
existing flow then you have the
opportunity after they've entered login
information and you validated that it's
correct you have the opportunity to
present them with that save dialog we
showed earlier and then once this
information is saved then next time they
come back they'll be able to do the
automatic
sign-in and in fact like I mentioned
earlier we had some big names there and
the performance on those apps has just
been really fantastic so for Netflix for
example huge hundred million users plus
they see in the order of thirty or forty
percent of their users being signed in
automatically with this that's that's a
complete change that those users you can
imagine are now reducing by basically
the same proportion all of their failed
login attempts so by incorporating a
couple of lines of code into your apps
letting it run for a little while to
collect you know the login information
from Android sign ends you're now
getting your users into a state where
they can be signed in automatically
almost half of the time and half of the
time will ultimately be the steady state
because when someone sees one of those
save dialogues we have in fact the
majority of people opt in to save so so
long as they have set up an account or
have signed in at least once they'll get
into that state and I think ultimately
where we see the kind of steady state
balance between chrome and Android being
is is the majority being originally
saved on Android so the idea being that
everyone who logs in on Android is shown
that prompt
it's a modal dialogue opt-in rates are
very good and the Android Android
scenario of user going from one device
to another either getting a new device
moving between devices signing out
restoring the app something like that is
very powerful and will be a very common
case so even if you only do Android
development it's worth thinking about
this but that said if you do have a
website it's worth putting the two
together so that they can share
credentials and in order to do that
there's a couple of steps in our
developer documentation but the general
idea here is that in order to ensure the
security of this of this connection you
assert ownership of the website that
you've got the one of the requirements
is that you have an HTTP site so just to
ensure that everything that's stored
there or retrieved there can be securely
passed to the user the general idea that
you assert ownership over your HTTP
website and then once you've got that
you go into the Play Developer console
and basically say that your app is
associated to that website and then with
that link made we can basically have the
credentials stored in either location be
available when the API is called in
chrome on the beta Channel or on Android
in the current version of Play services
so that's pretty cool experience
I think that really sums up what's
possible here and I think that if you
look at how it's been doing so far I
think one of the main points are the
stories that I'd like to tell is that
this is not just an API for kind of the
people who know what a password manager
is but in fact an API for anybody on
Android that in reality with some of the
big apps that have launched already we
have over 300 million downloads of the
of apps enabled with this API and we've
had 50 million people in just a few
months save or retrieve some kind of
login information and if you think about
that number that's more than any of the
password managers on Android have ever
been downloaded in the first place
so this is really aiming to be the login
solution for everyone that it's a state
or in a user experience where people
don't even have to think
about password management or login
management they just do whatever they
need to do they save that information
and they get in a state where they never
need to see or manage that information
again they'll just be signed in so
available on Android right now if you
check out developers.google.com slash
identity you can see the api's and how
to implement it integrate it into your
app there's a couple of guides there
about the user experience and the places
where you should make these API calls
pretty simple how to handle the
different corner cases and edge cases
things like logout or incorrect stored
password and if you're really interested
in that do you join us tomorrow there's
going to be a codelab session in the
morning I think it's at 9:30 a little
bit early but basically in a couple of
hours you'll be able to put these api's
into your app and get a lot of your
users in an experience where they just
don't need to think about logging in
anymore and that's really where we hope
to take all of this in the futures to
bring it to all platforms and basically
make it an experience where you can tap
on assisted sign-in dialog to create an
account make it very easy to get signed
up and then wherever you go you don't
need to worry about how to log back in
that's what we hope to bring to users
and I hope you'll join us tomorrow to
find out how to put it into your app
thank you